what the hell doesn't matter with you
sit down
i need to tell you something did you
toss my bike into the river deacon
hey guys pete here today i've got a
preview of episode six of mayor of east
town
i'm going to do a trailer breakdown and
discuss the theories i have
and then talk about some of the other
ones that are out there as well
as a warning this video will contain
speculation
and potential spoilers if you don't like
watching the trailers then this video is
definitely not for you and this is your
chance to get out of here and with that
out of the way let's get to it
as far as it goes mayor of east town is
certainly a character study and it might
be more about the town itself rather
than its human inhabitants
but it's also a mystery as we move along
it's pretty clear that
part of the way they unravel things is
by throwing out one or more characters
put them out front at the end of an
episode and make them look super guilty
only to ease off as we learn more
about their particular situation frank
sheehan and deacon mark are the most
blatant examples of this
as we get closer to the penultimate
episode they're getting ever
closer to running out a road with that
trick but having said that i
don't think they're at a place to reveal
what's really going on just yet
i brought this up in last week's preview
and theories video in relation to one of
my personal top suspects billy ross
showing that he's carrying a gun in his
tackle box brings him out
of the shadows part of the reason i
found him so suspicious was because he
was just hanging around
looking that way when they do that in
the trailer after the fourth episode
it makes you think that he can't be the
killer if you've been paying attention
this week we have a little more of that
with dylan and jess
and that's something that i'll come back
around to what i think that means and
how it changes up my thinking for the
finale
let's take a look at this trailer the
title card this time says next on
not in the weeks ahead which means we
should see all of these scenes in
episode 6. some of these overlap with
what we saw in the last trailer so i'll
bring that up when we see it
and there's a few other things still
kicking around out there that might be
important
as well the trailer opens with the chief
saying that he let hauser go this
morning
that mayor is going to take the case
back he gives her badge back
on his we see that it has a black band
around it that's a memorial for zabel i
would imagine
and just further evidence if you didn't
believe the interviews that he did
that colin is in fact dead hauser had
about 30 seconds of screen time so it's
not so surprising that she won't be
working with him
but based on these clips it does look
like the chief's gonna take an
active role in the investigation we see
them together
they're interviewing brianna and she
tells them that she woke up at two in
the morning and dylan wasn't in bed this
seems pretty on brand for brianna
she doesn't seem like the person you
want to cross and maybe she's developed
a conscience
since it is rather suspicious that dylan
was out on the night of aaron's murder
from there we see a shot of what i
presume is philly see the elevated train
there
that's probably related to the scenes
with billy and john we'll see later
mayor does bring dylan back in for
questioning saying
is there something you're trying to hide
and he lawyers up or he tries to lawyer
up and to that request she says yeah i
would too
and we can imagine that he will get a
lawyer and they might not get anything
out of him at this point
there's an aerial shot of what looks
like jon's truck driving along the river
i say it's jon's truck because i went
back and looked at episode 2 when they
pull up at kenny's
place it looks like the same one and in
the last trailer there was a similar
aerial shot of mare driving in this same
area
we see jon moving a mattress and hear
him say
what the hell is the matter with you to
a new character this is probably his
father since he's an older man
john left home in the last episode so
maybe he's staying with his dad
either way the new character says sit
down i need to tell you something
that cuts to a shot where he's walking
towards what looks like his laundry room
billy's already in there he's looking
frantic
and he slides the door closed to keep
him from seeing what's going on in there
we can't really see what it is it looks
like the washing machine is open
and there is a bottle of bleach behind
him in the shot which hints that he
might be trying to destroy
evidence but we don't actually see
anything on screen
then we see the chief ass deacon mark if
he threw aaron's bike into the river
and we see those shots of them pulling
the bike out of the water again it's
interesting that deacon mark has come
in we don't know if he got called or if
he came in on his own
the trailer makes it feel like he's
being questioned and while i tend to
believe the story he told father dan
there could be more to it and he's not
really in a good position to not be a
main suspect
in being the last person they know that
talked to her on the phone
and now to be the last person they know
to have seen her alive
then we get a different cut of this
scene of jess walking at night
near her apartment building this time we
hear her say just leave me alone
and dylan replies no that's impossible
then we see him bang on the car door
again and scream get in
now he's in his friend sean's car we saw
her with them
in the previous episode and in the
previous trailer dylan
added that the three of them were
connected forever
again we see her run away we see the car
speed off and her running down an
alley so they chase her and in both
trailers we saw her hiding underneath
the car and being pulled out from
underneath at the station we see a cop
say that jess is here to see mare
she has information about aaron
mcmenamin and then there's a shot of
mare holding a t-shirt that looks like
it says ross family reunion
it looks like this is an important
discovery for her like a light bulb just
went off over her head
but you can't really tell where she's at
or why
she made that connection there were
several posts on reddit where people
pointed out that we see
these ross family reunion shirts on her
instagram page when mare's watching that
one video
of course her last name is mcmenamin but
she's a cousin to the ross family so
it's not a big surprise that she would
be at their family reunion
but perhaps there's evidence on this or
where she found it is what's making this
an important find
after that we see billy looking tired
sipping on coffee
then we see him with the tackle box with
the gun in it ready to go again
there's a somewhat unconnected shot of
mayor walking it looks like she's
approaching a crime scene this could be
related to the bike or it could be
something we haven't seen yet
and then the trailer ends with the chief
saying get mirror on the phone
do it now and based on the last trailer
and that they showed the cop saying that
jess was at the station
i imagine this is right after she hands
him that photograph
which we saw that she grabbed out of the
journals in episode 5.
his command has an urgent tone to it so
this could be a situation where he now
knows who dj's father is and it's
something that mayor needs to know
immediately
if that information comes to light at
the end of episode six
that would set the stage for a finale
where the real story of what happened
the night of aaron's death can be
revealed
we have a one down two to go situation
the katy bailey mystery is solved
there isn't much indication that it's
connected to the two remaining mysteries
we still don't know who dj's father is
and what happened the night aaron was
killed
two crucial mysteries to go with two
episodes remaining
beyond brianna who we see is talking to
the cops we have three people who might
know more than what they've let on about
that night
the situation is as such that none of
them are very believable
deacon mark has a previous allegation of
sexual misconduct with the 14 year old
girl
he'd have an interest in concocting a
story that would ship the focus
away from him based on the timeline of
when they introduced him as a suspect
and everything we've seen since then
it's easy for
us as viewers to write him off as the
killer not so much for the cops
investigating him though
most of the characters who were
presented as the main suspect
all popped up too early for it to
actually be them
what does that say about dylan then
because they're sure making him look
pretty guilty right now there's not much
to like about this character
really the only thing they've even
hinted at being likable about him
is that he does appear to care about dj
even after learning that he's not the
biological father
beyond that he sucks and he's got at
least two big secrets going on
first he left the house on the night of
the murder after brianna fell asleep
from his initial interview with mayor we
know he went back there
after the fight and we did see them wake
up together the next morning when dj was
crying
in this trailer she says she woke up a
couple hours later at 2am and he
wasn't there from the medical examiner
we know the time of death was between
midnight and 2 a.m
and honestly there's no good explanation
for where he might have went
there is a popular theory out there that
he might be involved in drug dealing
this mostly stems from the idea that he
has this really nice car that he drives
around but his family's not super well
off
there may be something to that i mean he
wouldn't want anyone to know about it if
that's what he was doing
but at this point it's hard to connect
the dots on how that would influence
everything else that's going on
and literally there's not a lot to go
off of besides his car
and that we saw him smoking a joint with
sean when they picked up
jess of course the second secret is that
he conspired with
jess to destroy the journals that could
be connected
she knew him she would have known what
he was up to so there could be stuff
about that written in the journals
but i'm not really convinced obviously
he's no more believable than deacon mark
and his being her
ex makes him a likely suspect in the
eyes of the police
as far as jess is concerned she was
presented as a true friend when erin
came over that night before she went to
sharps woods
their friendship looked pretty genuine
and while we do see that dylan is
influencing her to mislead the police
after the fact
it doesn't really make sense that he
would have told her to go over there and
tell her about frank
remember mayor found out about that
before she went to the hospital and told
his parents there was a rumor that he
might not be the biological father when
his dad mentioned that to him
he seemed to be surprised with dylan
he's definitely got something going on
it's gonna put him on the radar of being
the killer again
the trailer makes that pretty clear and
it's certainly not impossible that
he might have met her at brandywine park
and something went wrong and she was
killed by accident
but beyond that it's pretty hard to
think of him just killing aaron
he sucks but is he a killer there's a
lot of room in between those two things
with jess it still makes the most sense
to me that she would be doing whatever
she's doing in an effort to honor her
friend's memory
she is conspiring with dylan however i
don't think that would be related to
some drug dealing or anything like that
considering she didn't exactly look
comfortable with smoking weed when shawn
passed her the joint in that car
also when they were together it didn't
seem like aaron knew about the two of
them
talking to each other joanna robinson
who writes for vanity fair wrote up a
pretty good theory about the end
i won't retell all of what she wrote
there i will put
a link to it in the description though
because it's worth a read
but she basically ended up on the idea
that they could be working together
because they both want to keep who the
real father is a secret
if the police had the journals and they
found out who the father was
then dylan's family would lose dj and
that is something that we heard
just say that aaron lied about dylan
being the father because she really
wanted his parents to be in dj's life
that does make sense however it doesn't
explain what we've seen in the last two
trailers
something about this is gonna fall apart
i'm presuming that when we saw jess
pocket that picture
it is something that would reveal who
the real father is
that would explain why dylan didn't want
her to go to the police but really
nothing about how we get to that point
other than maybe she never knew until
she read the journals
and it's just been eating away at her
because it'll help solve the case
aaron herself still has some secrets we
want to know the answers to
the locket that mayor found we don't
know what that's all about
and we also saw dylan pocket some money
that she had managed to save up for the
ear surgery
it's not really clear where she got that
it didn't look like too much maybe a
couple hundred bucks
but it does hint that something else is
going on
from there the focus does shift onto the
ross family
like i said in my last video i do
imagine that the killer will turn out to
be someone that we've met but we haven't
fully suspected yet
i was thinking about billy but now he's
firmly on the radar
now that mayer knows they lived together
and he got freaked out
and left after she found out we saw her
staring at the beer bottle
it's possible that she'll try to use
that to collect his dna
but i'm still kind of leaning towards
that picture being the clue that's going
to break things wide open
either way it's clear that mayer was
thinking about how he might be connected
to things
after hearing he lived with aaron billy
isn't looking like the best suspect
anymore
although i think it is possible that he
could still be the father
but this whole situation with ryan and
john is really starting to make you
wonder if jon isn't actually the one we
need to be looking at
he made a point of providing an alibi
for frank which also gave him an alibi
for that night
that certainly feels suspicious the
whole way that the idea of the affair
played out seems a little bit suspicious
too
laurie put the answers into ryan's mouth
he never said it himself he only nodded
yes at the end
and he could have been trying to make
the whole thing stop
those two might be carrying a big secret
the reason billy looks so suspicious all
the time might also be because he knows
about it
and in this trailer it looks like he has
some kind of culpability
or he was doing something that he was
trying to cover up that their father
knows about
i think there's a good chance that what
ryan knows will play a big part in
figuring out the end
i think finding out dj's father will
also be key
and it's kind of exciting that john's
father's going to him to tell him
something
where he might be giving that
information up to the exact wrong person
even if jon isn't guilty he would
probably cover things up for his brother
and considering that they've made the
choice to present mare as a crooked cop
it does leave things open and make you
wonder how she'll react to that
considering that laurie's her best
friend based on removing the characters
i've mentioned
if it's not jon who does that leave
richard siobhan
laurie father dan ryan and frank and
faye
ryan's a kid and he would have had to
get there with a gun
and get the body to the river after that
would involve an
accomplice but it would also involve him
being a killer
it seems more likely he probably found
out something he wasn't supposed to
it might spill the beans father dan is
the same
all things considered he isn't very
shady
i think richard serves an obvious
purpose to be there for mayor after what
happened to colin
we've seen them kissing in the last
trailer and know that he's still trying
to be in her life
there may be ulterior motives involved
or he
may have more secrets but they would
have to do a hard
turn to setting it up for it to make
sense for him to be revealed as the
killer at this point
yes guy pierce is a well-known actor and
he does seem to be a little
underutilized
right now but in all the press materials
he is listed below
lori helen siobhan and colin i mean if
mayer found that ross family reunion
shirt at his place that would definitely
change things
but short of something like that i think
richard is low on the suspect list
lori seems like a stretch to me all the
way around in the last episode we saw
her husband leave the house when she
found out he was having an affair
would she really kill a sweet single
teen mother that they
know personally because she found out
that she was abused by that same husband
siobhan's role in the big picture is a
little unclear
i said a few episodes back that i
thought she was there
she has the documentary in that she was
a connection to kevin in that period of
time for mayor
it also seems like she's the only
character who has a chance to get out of
east town
and her splitting with becca makes it
seem really unlikely that they would
have had secrets about that
night together there is this persisting
theory that kevin hooked up with aaron
and he's the one who's really dj's
father and that could be something that
siobhan could find out but i don't
really
see how that would be all that important
to the story
if you play it all the way out it would
just mean that mare has two grandkids at
the end instead of one
there is something going on with frank
and faye but neither one of them seem
like killers to me
and they're really not on my suspect
list at this time
in the end i think jon is the best
suspect at this point
is he dj's dad maybe is billy the dad
and john knows and he's been covering
for him this whole time
maybe it could be the other way around
it could be
that jon killed aaron to protect his
brother or
vice versa we'll have to wait and see i
think jess ryan and laurie will be the
key players
in bringing the information to mayor
then we'll see how it all plays out
and what kind of effect it has on east
town i think that's a good place to
leave it
please like this video if you enjoyed it
let me know in the comments what you
think
who are your top suspects where do you
think this thing's going what other
secrets keep kicking around in your
brain
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already i'll be doing two mayor
of east town videos again next week so
make sure you check
back thanks for watching i'll talk to
you soon